hello rejects its Greg Alda here and I'm
John John John John and I are gonna
watch the trailer for the highly
requested sequel XXX the return of
xander cage
yeah I've been waiting for this who
hasn't been most people that's not true
I know
well everyone Vin Diesel did not return
first State of the Union
what and now we're getting him here are
I smile I don't remember the first one
that well and I never saw the second one
but it's been in many years so I'm sure
this is like some kind of soft reboot
thing they're probably gonna be doing
three you want an uber you could have
just asked me what is this a device that
controls every military satellite in the
world
we've fallen into the hands of four very
dangerous guy I'm Donnie Donnie Yen we
need someone who can move like them I
like them damn yeah there are no more
Patriots just rubble and tyrants which
are you I'm xxx I'll introduce you to
your ground team all right it comes Red
Hills poster child clowns watch my back
who would you trust you just kill those
boys today I got what you need about the
team I can work with
refreshing if you know what you're doing
down there that's what she said
wow these guys are the real kind of
trouble you Donna yeah man put you up
against whatever Jews are looking for
we're gonna come off short
this is mean you're not making me
breakfast and we're willing to die to
keep the world safe how about you I live
for this I guess we're on the same team
no you're right have some fun
we simplify for you it is insane
no I feel like I've seen our guru and
tried to look dope boy
whoa god damn that was a nutty trailer
yes isn't that crazy it's like a crank
movie holy [ __ ] yeah that was nuts
mmm-hmm seems like they really learned
from what happened with Fast and the
Furious they're like let's do that to
xxx let's just going crazy as we
possibly can now I could be wrong about
this but again it's just my opinion I
remembered when I saw the first xxx
feeling like this is unintentionally bad
and unintentionally cheesy like it's
ridiculous it's [ __ ] ridiculous but I
felt like they were still trying to make
like a cool yeah yeah serious movie it'd
be cool but also be really over the top
of the time like you have to acknowledge
yep don't be based on yeah that's a fast
and furious did yeah they try being more
serious cooler films and they were and
then when they finally embrace the
ridiculousness of it with Fast Five then
the franchise took a whole new life and
it's exactly what they're doing here
instead of trying to make it look like
it's something more than what it is
they're just going let's head out this
is just very crazy take this done not so
the only people doing like extreme
sports related stunts right now Point
Break didn't pan out in December
whatever that was like if this movie is
anything like its trailer I'm going to
enjoy it I really I don't really like it
it can
I don't feel like it cannot be like
there's no I much [ __ ] in this trailer
I'm like I feel like we've seen
something out of most scenes of the
Damned your most Lilly's major scenes
and like yeah it looks nuts and and like
and Doni ends in this tune I don't know
that's the highlight of the trailer to
me yeah yeah it's kicking some serious
ass in here Ninh he doesn't look like
he's just some cool little supporting
Asian character role like they're giving
him a lot of he's featured heavily in
this trailer so first I kind of make him
look like he's the villain then he's
working with him or was he I have no
full trade ain't going pretending to be
his friend like I'm not sure exactly
what
or at least they have that criminal
thing where they like they respect each
other still cuz they both know that they
got a code and a lot of skills yeah
regardless though it was really cool to
see like Dan they're really showcasing
Donnie and in this trailer well that's
what sold like that's what really
started to click for me when I watch
this is like the second he showed up and
they actually showed him like doing some
legit ass you know martial arts fighting
like that was on the trailer won me over
and then everything got bigger and
bigger yeah cuz like I'll I'll admit
board it just look like Dominic's ready
yeah yeah yeah and and then like going
into watching this trailer I was I just
didn't think that there was a way I was
gonna be interested in this and I mean
you know I'm not like I can't wait but
but yeah especially in January like this
looks like it's a great January yeah
like one of those January movies that
knows it's not like like hard-hitting
enough to be the summer but hey man
let's have a nice time let's hell yeah I
mean it looks like they threw down for
this movie there's a lot of crazy ass
visuals that are going on crazy ass
visuals and also like a really what
seems like a really you know diverse and
and broadcast yeah cool like it's like
punch it's very kinetic this trailer I
love it I had you two really enjoyed it
just like this is so ridiculous I can't
help but enjoy this if Donnie Yen died
I'm just so happy he's getting like a
really cool role out there yeah you know
I don't know all the food the few
American films we'll see them in our
blade - yeah it's just like side
character Asian dude on the team and
then he's in Shanghai Knights were yeah
he's kind of like a secondary villain
and he like punches somebody yeah he
fights Jackie Chan and decent fight
that's right okay and now he's coming
out of rogue one ever since a release of
it man or Ip Man constantly forget he's
really banned
yeah believe it's just it man ever since
that like people have really wanted him
back more in the States
because those are huge international
films and I feel like you know this
makes sense in terms of how they do
marketing with films like road one comes
out in December and a lot of people are
speculating that Donnie yen's gonna be
the highlight of row one the really
standout character and then January
comes around and here he is co-star
we've been diesel one of the biggest
action stars right now this could be the
wave where we really start to see more
Donnie Yen like
this will be the second thing that comes
out immediately after row one do we know
that yeah and I'm sure I'm sure other
movies like you have taught us this you
know before these examples like lately
it seems like especially in like you
know big action movies that we've
learned a couple nice lessons from both
fast and furious and movies like the
raid we really like big fun action but
we also really seem to have a greater
appreciation now for actual fighting and
martial arts and like stuff that takes
time to choreograph like choreography
has become impressive again or I feel
like it kind of fell off for a while cuz
that was kind of a frustrating trend I
feel like where it's like ah let's get a
great guy from like Hong Kong cinema and
bring him to America and not give him a
whole lot to do I'm glad to see that the
done Ian's having sort of a comeback in
America well work that way for Jackie
Chan too like Jackie Chan came out and
he did like a couple of American films
and then he went away for many years
then they came out with a release rumble
in the Bronx over here this early so
Bob's Asian films and he got a rush hour
and I kind of feel like Donnie yen's
have a sort of similar path in where he
he like came out in America for a while
nothing really happened there but then
after hitman came over here and gonna
need a lot of success so now down he
ends really coming on the map and a lot
of people and a lot of people really you
know excited for I like I I didn't even
know he was in this yeah I didn't have
the people and I don't like they're a
bunch of faces I recognized in here nice
as you say I'm Jackson back again he
usually has the fro or not Oh daddy I
like hair huh we're gonna say look
different this well yeah yeah he's still
doing all those marbles oh that's good
yeah he looks like Sam Jackson in a
movie like this yeah Tony Jaa's motion
Thomas as well holy [ __ ] oh I'm
definitely tuning into this justice in
hopes they have a fight scene together
yeah
Tony Jaa was in Furious 7 Vin Diesel
he's honing an Asian actors I like it
and it's directed by the guy who did
disturbia and Eagle Eye dunkaroo so yeah
cool
after watching eagle eye could see DJ
Caruso doing this yeah this seems like a
better this looks like a great cheesy
time this looks like a great way to at
least reestablish himself cuz i haven't
heard his name in a while and and hey
man if this is fun i'm sure you learn
want to Google alright rejects if I knew
the channel subscribe to didn't get
accepted John is it has his social media
stuff in the description box and I don't
want to say at all them but I do
facebook.com/ slash Blum has
facebook.com slash Lee my name rejects
one more time you know what man